Ya, como ya sabéis, han enviado las listas.
Esas son las fechas oficiales directamente con
los días que van a dissertar en base a eso.
Y los demás pues que ya no estaban,
ya no se tomó en cuenta los que ya no han existido clases.
Pero en este caso, hoy voy a hacer la última clase,
vamos a tratar de terminar algunos puntos más y tener casi todo terminado.
Ya va a haber un módulo 2, ahí es demasiado, un poquito más avanzado.
Ahí tenemos cosas más interesantes, pero voy a hacer la parte más interesante también.
Así que empezaremos con la parte de,
abrimos de una vez tanto Docker como tanto un 8n.
Ya vamos a empezar.
Ya, la parte que voy a hacer es un poquito más autónomo,
así que si le quieren ustedes aplicar esos proyectos, será interesante.
Ya, pero voy a abrir Docker más.
Y listo.
Ahora sí.
Mientras vamos abriendo todo este aspecto,
voy a comentarles que generalmente
vayan abriendo su Google Console para habilitar unos puntos que voy a trabajar.
Bueno, y lo voy a habilitar con ustedes.
Listo.
Ahí ven a colocar Cloud.
Bonsoir.
Listo.
Perdón.
Vamos a hacer mejor acá.
Google Cloud.
Listo.
Vamos a Google Cloud directamente ahí.
Con la página que han trabajado netamente para sus permisos y credenciales,
con esa misma tienen que trabajar.
Dentro a Consola.
Y dentro de Consola, voy a irme a lo siguiente.
Creo que ya lo tengo habilitado, pero vos lo con ustedes de cero.
Mientras habilitándose mi 8n.
Bueno, ya se habilitó, creo.
Así que, podemos esperar a ver.
A no estar, está todavía cargando el mío.
Listo.
Es el que habíamos trabajado con ustedes.
Entonces, se van a venir acá.
Van a irse a ApiService.
Se van a ir a Biblioteca.
Ya.
Mientras tanto, sigue prendiéndose.
En acá, van a colocar, en este caso, Google Calendar.
Ya.
Lo buscan.
Aquí está Google Calendar API.
Y ahí es el que es Calendar Using Caldap.
Ya.
Ambos sirven.
El primer te lo van a habilitar.
Ya.
A Google Calendar API.
Paz en clic.
Y directamente lo habilitan.
Aquí va a estar lo que ustedes habilitar.
Ya.
De mí ya.
Ya se habilita por eso me dicen mini charmes.
Ya.
Una vez que tengan eso, aprovecharemos para irnos a
Credenciales.
ApiService, Credenciales.
Esto partida sabemos, así que no hay problema.
Y si es que se han olvidado, como les había comentado,
ni que notarse si o si su ID y su clave secreta en un blog de
notas, les había comentado, no es?
El mío lo borró.
Así que voy a volver a habilitar.
Creo que lo tengo, pero por ese caso.
Ya.
¿Qué dice aquí?
Docker failed.
¿Qué digo?
¿Qué hago?
Esto es un video de coquiticia.
A ver.
Esto demora un ratito.
Voy a tratar de habilitar a mí, Docker.
Siempre pasa esto, así que un terribulo no se ha pasado.
Así que prefiero abrirlo desde el sistema de un ratito.
Voy a evitar Docker mientras tanto voy a eliminar Docker.
Ya.
Pero no más, si no, se va a tratar de eliminar.
Ya, listo.
Entonces acá se viene en la parte inferior y esta partecita
se tiene que acordar tanto su clave secreta como su cuenta,
ya como su ID de cliente.
Si se han olvidado y tienen aquí dos generados,
no las va a querer un tercero, así que eliminenlo no más.
Ya es lo más aconsejable que se les puede administrar.
Ya, esperamos que mi Docker abra de nuevo.
Ya, listo.
Eso copiense en un blog de notas y voy a abrir un blog de notas.
Internamente lo voy a copiar.
Ya, les doy a saber a ustedes.
No hay problema.
Esto está corriendo recién, así que vamos a estimar un sponsor.
Bueno, yo ya lo tengo.
Ya, les voy a pasar un documento más ahorita para que tengan todo en cuenta.
Pero en este caso ya tengo mi secret e mi ID, ya,
del que acabo de mostrarles de Google Cloud Console.
Bueno, que se actualiza y empezamos.
O sea, mientras tanto, ojalá que estuviese actualizando.
Seguro hasta cargando mi Docker.
Ahora, mientras va habilitándose y demás,
lo más aconsejable es que si van a trabajar lo de manera local,
así lo colocan en una computadora de escritorio.
Y así ya lo dejan prendido y normal va a estar funcionando todo el día 24-7,
si es posible.
Ya, pero si van a trabajar en un entorno,
obviamente, de compra, ya no hay problema de estar ensalviendo,
apagando porque ya funciona 24-7 de los 365 días del año.
Así que, eso vean lo.
Pero yo, en este caso, bueno, en lo personal,
yo siempre trabajo local para no gastar dinero.
Y normal me funciona siempre cuando le adapto a una computadora,
PC, de escritoria.
Ahí está.
Ya, no se recomienda lo en laptops, porque las laptops se reinician, etc.
Hay un montón de problemas en el autopsismo.
Ya hago doble clic.
Ya hay que esperar un rato.
Ya vamos a esperar un rato para que se actualiza
y que vaya habilitándose mi Docker.
Ya, sigue está activándose.
Ya, entonces ya debes traiguar mi NACHON, así que ya está mi NACHON,
así que apretó la tecla O y habilitamos.
Ya, ahora este rato también lo voy a actualizar.
Y listo.
Si no les quiere dar, por eso no es porque,
a veces, hay que secos y ya hay que esperar acá de unos 10 minutos,
es posible.
No es necesario forzarlo, digamos.
En caso extremo que no fuese de los 10 minutos,
o sea, ahí sí, hay que entrar a lo que voy a hacer, digamos.
Ya voy a venir acá.
Y dentro de acá dice,
View Details.
Ahí se entra.
Ahí está Corri.
Esto va a estar cargándose.
Y hay que esperar ahí.
Ahí está cargándose automáticamente.
Ya, y voy a volver a actualizar.
Ya, si no actualiza de nuevo,
pueden forzarlo también, no hay problema.
En mi caso, yo lo forzo de esta manera, digamos.
Vengo acá.
Le hago el doble clic derecho y dos veces clic izquierdo
y le hago el abrir de nuevo.
Ya.
Y hay que esperar un rato.
Ya, listo.
Pero, mientras tanto, me he hecho una vuelta.
Está trabajando hasta que se vaya actualizando.
Ya, entraremos de una vez en el último trabajo, chicos.
Ya.
Listo.
Ahí no me acuerdo.
Con el canso.
¿Qué era eso?
Ya.
Ya, listo.
Ya se activó el bar mitócara, así que empezaremos.
Ya, voy a crear un nuevo workflow.
Ya, de la siguiente manera van a presentar sus trabajos.
Especificando algunos nodos.
Ya, ahorita voy a explicar cómo te lo tengo.
Ya, ahora sí.
Empezaremos.
Vamos a hacerlo tanto en producción como tanto en semántica.
Ya, así que de modo reto.
Directamente venimos a la parte suma.
Y voy a empezar a trabajar como webhooks, por webhooks.
Ya.
Vengo acá y directamente voy a hacer lo siguiente.
Ya, vamos a la primera prueba.
Y van a hacer lo siguiente también.
Dentro de acá, ya saben, vayan entrando hacia manager.
Y ya tiene que estar en la estadía de su número.
Ya.
En este caso, ahí no me acuerdo esta parte.
Ya pique globar.
Ya, vamos a hacer lo siguiente.
Entonces, voy a abrir con mi otra cuenta.
De un ratito para no estar volviendo.
Acordame las cuentas.
Localhost777.
Listo, voy a abrir por la otra faceta.
Ya.
Y ya.
Ahora te lo sumo.
Ya, listo.
Esto lo voy a hacer lo que estoy abriendo otro navegador.
Así que.
Ya está.
Ahí está el mío.
Ya.
Con mi cuenta y no hay nada más.
Ahora sí, empezaremos.
Lo primero que voy a hacer es sintonizar el sistema.
Ya, así que para sintonizar esta parte directamente voy a generar posil.
URL.
A o clic directamente esto.
Pueden colocar en producción o URL.
Cuando ya terminen el proyecto de sintonización y esto automáticamente ya escucha.
Entonces, no hay que estar haciendo.
Lícen por Ted Sivenos haciendo.
Haciendo cada rato apretando el botón de escuchar y no.
Esto es de manera automática y es de manera manual.
Puedo llamar test.
Voy a colocar método post.
Y listo.
Ya.
Una vez que tenga tengamos eso y hay que trabajar con algún tipo de test.
Para la parte de test.
Voy a trabajar de esta manera.
Ya, listo.
Me voy a copiar esta parte.
Este local host.
Ya me voy a copiar.
Voy a irme directamente a mi evolución.
Entro.
Voy a irme a eventos.
Voy a irme a webhooks.
Y dentro de mi webhook.
Voy a tratar de trabajar con esto.
Ya voy a copiarlo acá todo.
Controle.
Y aquí ya sabía comentado.
No sé que no sabía.
Mente docker que estoy manejando.
Así que hay que generarle un aspecto interno.
Para eso lo sabía comentar que yo se ve host.
En este caso punto docker.
Punto interno.
Ya.
Dos puntos, tantos tantos.
Con eso se va a escuchar.
Ahora esto tienen que habilitarlo.
Ustedes ya que no está habilitado.
Y tienen que habilitar en este caso el.
Message.
Observe para recibir y enviar mensajes.
Y luego lo guardan.
Ya.
Como ya está escuchando.
Con mi evolución API.
Directamente esto ya puede escuchar.
Ahora.
Cuando yo lo integro a mi.
Internal.
O sea.
A lo que les acabo de mostrar.
Ya está trabajando con mi número interno.
O sea.
Ya está trabajando con tal cual lo he programado.
El.
Evolución API.
Así que.
Voy a enviarme un mensaje.
Ya de morroto.
Voy a enviarme un mensaje desde mi otro.
Número.
Eso tiene que hacer ustedes igual.
Mandarse mensajes.
Entonces.
Voy a venir acá.
Iguales.
Pueden enviarme mensajes ahorita.
El número que estoy trabajando acá.
Es mi.
Este.
766.
58749.
Esa es de mi empresa.
Y ahí pueden ahorita escribir.
Y se va a escuchar.
Y van a capturar sus datos.
Pero.
Lo voy a trabajar.
Yo.
A ver de más ratito.
Lo voy a mandar desde otro número.
Ya puedo trabajar de manera así.
Listo.
Los ahorramos.
Y puedo escuchar.
Voy a escribirle.
Lo voy a decir hola.
Listo.
Allí me capturaron los datos.
Ya.
Es mi webhook función.
Ahí está.
A dónde.
Fíjense de dónde estoy escribiendo.
Yo.
Desde mi número personal.
Ahí me está capturando.
Los.
Una vez que tenemos eso ya podemos trabajar con ya con métodos un poquito más complejos.
Para hacerlo algo más interesante y más estructurado.
Lo más aconsejable es que cuando ustedes trabajen ya con cosas un poquito más específicas y grandes.
Y empiecen a utilizar los stickers.
Los stickers generalmente lo llevan ahí.
Lo ven ahí.
Ahí.
Ya.
Y aquí van a hacer el doble clic.
Y lo van a borrar esto.
No interés esto.
Ahí van a colocar mensajes entrantes.
Mensajes entrantes.
Listo.
Ya está.
Ahí lo acomoda bonito.
Y ahí pueden darle descripciones de qué está haciendo.
Porque hay veces cuando ya son sistemas bien gigantes.
Ya no le sabrán de qué nodo está haciendo tal nodo.
Ya entonces.
Una vez que ya está en mi web publico designado.
Puedo trabajar ya con lo que son mis edit files.
Para capturar y demás.
Entonces vengo a edit files.
Saco.
Y lo voy a conectar directamente acá.
Ya.
Y aquí igual.
Van a colocar su sticker y van a colocarlo acá.
Otro trabajan en formato blanco.
Esto se ve más elegante, pero.
Y lo trabajo así.
Voy a colocarlo así.
Y aquí doble clic y va lo mismo.
Van a colocar en este caso.
Lo que es captura de datos.
Captura.
De datos.
Del cliente.
Listo.
Ya está.
Ya.
Una vez que tengamos eso.
Tenemos que procesar los datos.
O sea que quiero que captura y demás.
Así que hago doble clic.
Y siempre van a trabajar de manera manual.
El mapeo.
A no ser que quieran hacerlo automáticamente.
Solo les voy a enseñar luego.
Ya lo que yo necesito.
Siempre es atrapar el dato de la instancia.
Ya.
De la instancia.
Esta es la instancia.
Ya.
Es decir.
Con qué número estoy trabajando.
O sea con qué número de cuenta institucional.
O de whatsapp.
O de sus personales.
Mejor de whatsapp.
Entonces.
Van a ver que cuando yo.
Halo instancia.
Debería de aparecer aquí.
Mi empresa dos.
Y eso está con la cual estás registrado.
Mi.
Mi volución API.
Ya.
El otro.
Es que voy a tratar de trabajar con el server.
Ya con el server.
Es decir.
Para que detecte cuál es la.
Aplicación interna.
Ya.
Ok.
Aquí dice server.
URL.
Ya.
Con el local.
Jajajajajaja.
Hay lo calo y listo.
Ahora esta parte.
Yo les recomiendo que.
Siempre lo borren esto.
El body.
Y solamente coloquen.
A instancia.
Server.
El body.
En otras palabras.
Ahora voy a trabajar con el.
Aplicar.
El Aplicar.
Me va a degenerar un proceso mucho más.
Verídico.
Y que no.
Obviamente no.
No.
No es problema.
O mensajes con otros usuarios.
O su maneja.
Aplicar.
Igual acá.
Lo colocan y lo borran.
Solamente lo dejan como.
Aplicar.
Una vez que ganes.
O.
Ahí.
Podemos trabajar con más.
Formas.
Incluso.
A ver.
Voy a trabajar con el.
Remote.
A mi.
Hay.
J.
Y.
Aquí está.
Esto por ejemplo.
Va a capturar.
Quién me está escribiendo.
Hago clic.
Lo jaló acá.
Aquí lo mismo.
Pueden mantenerlo.
Esto.
Del nombre.
Pero yo lo veo muy.
Feo.
Pero.
Lo voy a colocar en el número.
Porque estoy capturando el número.
Luego.
Quiero capturar el nombre.
También.
Lo voy a colocar en el número.
Luego.
Quiero capturar el nombre.
También.
De quién me está escribiendo.
Así que para esa parte.
Voy a irme directamente.
Ah.
Lo que es.
El.
Push.
Name.
Ya.
Algo más.
Podemos sacar.
Antes de eso.
A ver.
Qué más podemos.
Todos estos son necesarios.
Pero.
En la mayoría de los casos.
No es tan.
Medio.
No.
Que tan.
Urgente hacerlo.
Pero.
Depende de qué aplicaciones.
Quieran capturar sus datos.
Del cliente.
Ya.
Aquí está.
Push.
Name.
Igual.
Lo mantienen.
O lo colocan como.
Nombre nomás.
Y luego.
En este caso.
El mensaje.
A ver.
Donde está mi mensaje.
Y de usted.
Ya.
Hay dice.
Hola.
Aquí dice.
Conversación.
Ya.
Eso lo.
Jalan.
Listo.
Aquí pueden colocar en vez de conversación.
Mientras.
Listo.
Qué más podemos sacar.
Bueno, mucho.
Tiene que ver qué cosas que se quieren capturar.
Lo más.
Un aplicativo yo necesito.
Lo ejecuto directamente.
Y debería de capturar todos los datos que estamos ahorita trabajando.
Nada más.
Pasaremos al siguiente sistema.
Y.
No.
Se va a hacer que mas nos pasara.
Es.
Más.
Al siguiente sistema.
Una vez que tengan eso.
Vamos.
Entrarnos a nuestro agente.
A nos hi.
Y.
Agents.
Listo.
Esta.
Parte.
Lo mismo.
Tiene que trabajar.
Venimos.
Acá.
Generó el systemita.
Mis.
Estickers.
Y automáticamente.
vamos a colocar directamente analítica de datos y procesos.
Hacemos clic.
Y ya está.
Me da disculpas si tengo horrores ortográficos.
La cuestión es que quiero terminar de una vez y no se vamos
a traser horriblemente porque es tan largo.
Pero contar que las funcione normal va a funcionar todo.
Una vez que generan ahí, aquí es un poquito medio
complicado ya de darles los prompts.
Ya los voy a pasar con prompts.
Ya hecho, el prompt tiene casi 15 páginas.
Pero ustedes lo pueden modernizar,
lo pueden reducir en base al proyecto que ustedes quieran.
Bueno, en este caso voy a elegir mi modelo y ir con el
típico que utilizamos.
Listo.
Ya está.
Listo, ya tenemos ahí.
Luego le voy a añadir una memoria simple para que se
acuerde con qué usuario está trabajando y una simple memoria.
Listo.
Ahora sí, una vez que hayamos hecho eso,
ya podemos trabajar un poquito con la memoria para que no
pierden contexto con el cliente.
Porque siempre es bueno.
Así que hago lo doble que memoria.
Van a colocar acá define below dentro de la simple memory.
Y en acá vamos a hacer lo siguiente.
A ver, voy a irme a mi.
La quita aunque jalar.
O sea, para que se acuerde con quién está hablando,
cómo la key no puede cambiar.
Así que normal es.
Ya esto.
Podemos utilizar el remote.
JID o el remote.
Ya esto es muy independiente de cuámo quieran trabajar.
Pero yo voy a trabajar con este ID.
Con este ID es mejor.
Porque estos pueden tener conversa.
Obviamente es el mismo número, pero las conversaciones pueden
ser solapadas.
Así que prefieres trabajar con el ID para que se acuerde
incluso en diferentes fechas.
Una vez que tengan eso, van a hacer lo siguiente.
Generalmente el contexto, o sea, la conversación para que se
memorice, se lo puede.
Aquí dice, how many pass interaction the model.
Si eso es lo que anda.
Pueden, máximo, y los recomiendo que trabajen con 12.
Porque imagínense con su cliente, ustedes, no creo que la
IA hable más de 12 conversaciones.
O sea, 24 conversaciones y desigualtos.
Sería algo ilógico.
No hay mucho de eso.
No sé qué sea algo.
Un negocio muy, muy, muy específico.
Pero ahí entraría la persona.
Si quiere algo más específico y ya se ha hecho una transacción o
la venta y ya se ha hecho realmente ideal o idónea,
ahí sí se puede meter.
Y los recomiendo 10, 12, máximo.
Yo lo voy a dejar con 6.
Entonces, lo cierro.
Ya está.
Y esta es su memoria guardada.
Ahora voy a irme directamente a asignar algunas herramientas.
Para las herramientas, obviamente,
yo quiero que me envíe una respuesta al WhatsApp y,
obviamente, a los diferentes tipos de webbooks que puedo
crearme.
Entonces, voy a trabajar con un HTTP requests para que me
envíe al sistema.
Lo cierro y aquí voy a jalar esto.
Listo.
Demórito.
Ahora sí, voy a jalar otro y lo voy a otro sticker.
Y mientras más crees que su sistema,
más stickers recomendable que tenga.
¿Pero qué?
Porque a veces puede haber un montón de nodos que quizás
ustedes estaban a majar más de 20 webcocks.
Ahí va a ser el problema de no saber qué está haciendo tal
cosa.
Voy a colocar respuesta al cliente de WhatsApp.
Listo.
Ya está.
Una vez que tengamos eso, hay configurar el HTTP.
Configuramos el HTTP.
Hago doble clic.
Y aquí generalmente hay que colocar el URL.
La URL podemos sacar lo de lo que es el test message.
Lo voy a hacer con ustedes esta parte.
A ver, voy a pasarles esto para no perder tiempo.
No, voy a entrar este mietro.
Ya, si no se, si por eso es del cino lo pierdan,
no sé qué les voy a pasar.
Puedo venir acá desde documentaciones.
En documentaciones se van directamente a,
donde está esta casa, más abajo está.
Aquí dice, Evolution API, Evolution Go, esto, esto.
¿Qué es esto?
Deferencia de API dice.
Aquí dice, más abajo me voy a ir.
O acá, donde está.
Ya, opción listo, aplicación, aquí está.
Y me voy a ir a autenticación.
¿Dónde estaba la otra evolución?
Sí, vamos a seguirnos.
Ya.
Es lo malo que a veces actualiza y ya no sé
sabe dónde está.
Pero para que no sufran todo eso,
os voy a pasar esto.
Ya está.
No estoy enviando al grupo, perdón, a la mensajería de MIT.
Y ahí, listo.
Yo lo estoy enviando.
Ya se guarden, ¿sí?
¿Por qué a veces actualiza y se va a costar en contra?
Pero está.
Si yo no sé tarde, le encuentro hasta 10 minutos cada vez
que se actualiza el sistema.
Ya, cuando les pasa, el URL se van a ir directamente a,
aquí, Dicente Smash.
Y todo esto lo que hemos hecho en varias clases,
tenemos que copiarlo y adaptarlo.
Pero aquí es un poquito diferente.
Pero hay que, esa es la base fundamental que nos va a dar.
Ya.
Una vez que tengan eso, vamos a hacer lo siguiente.
A ver, vamos a hacer esto.
Generalmente, la URL que voy a manejar,
haremos un bitito, a ver si.
Ya, de nuevo, método POST.
Y aquí, si no saben qué colocar, aquí dice,
Parametro Requirements.
Ahí hacen click y les va a bilitar 90.
Sabe tardar, pero si no les abre,
vamos a hacer un texto plano.
Así que pesa parte, vamos a encontrar acá.
A ver, voy a jalar, en este caso, mi server.
Y mis edit fields, donde está server.
Ah, voy a jalar.
Ya, eso lo van a jalar.
El servidor que estamos manejando.
Así lo vas a aparecer.
Edit fields.
Ahora, fíjense lo que voy a hacer.
Voy a irme de nuevo a mi Evolution API.
No me interesa ya mucho esto.
No me interesa esta parte.
Ya me interesa esto.
Esta parte.
Aquí hay otros más, si se dan cuenta.
Hay otros aspectos técnicos que ya se le puede referenciar.
Pero si copio esto, se copia automáticamente.
Lo pueden llevar a un blog de notas.
Voy a mostrar un blog de notas.
Voy a abrir uno nuevo.
Ahí lo pueden copiar lo que se han pegado.
Ya, fíjense, todo esto es mi servidor.
Todo es mi servidor ahorita, o sea, esta cosa.
Ya, esta cosa.
Todo esto es mi servidor, porque es mi servidor URL.
Solo me la estoy jalando para que se actualice automáticamente.
Ahora, ¿qué viene?
Si nos damos cuenta acá, ahí voy a colocarlo.
Ya, voy a hacerlo así mejor.
Esto lo voy a minimizar.
Ya, ahí está.
Miren.
Servidor, luego voy a cocar el Message, Send Text, y Slash,
Insertar en Instances.
La Instance, el nombre de la Instance, y que Instalar.
Ya, en esta parte si te voy a copiar.
Copio y lo voy a pegar.
Ya, esta Instancia es mi Jason.
Ya, Jason Instance.
A ver, ¿cuál era mi Instancia anteriormente?
Aquí está, empresa 2, ¿no?
Entonces, eso lo voy a borrar esta cierta parte.
¿Listo?
Y ahí lo voy a dejar la Instance.
Entonces, eso es lo que yo necesito.
Ya.
Aquí debería de aparecerme Verde, ¿no?
Para que ver si está habilitándose.
Pero en algunos aspectos no va a aparecer,
porque no estoy ejecutándolo todavía.
No está generándome la respuesta de IA.
Ya.
Ahora, vamos a enviar los cabezas, las gidas o las coches.
Los gidas o los cabezas.
Send gidas, voy a colocar.
Y aquí en using, voy a ponerle más facilidad,
pero vamos a hacer lo normal, lo más.
Ahora, dentro de los gidas, sí o sí, voy a volver acá.
Aquí tengo dos cabezas.
Content drive, esto tal cual se lo copia.
Y la api-key.
Ya, aquí es un poquito diferente a lo que hemos hecho
en anterior clase.
Pero lo voy a copiar.
Lo voy a pegar acá donde estoy, esa cosa.
OK.
Ya, pego.
Y también voy a pegar el otro, ¿no?
Esta parte, Application Gease.
¿Ya?
Ya está.
Ya, otro header voy a hacer.
Vengo acá, otro.
Lo mismo, api-key.
Hago click y lo voy a generar acá.
Ahora está api-key, ya lo tengo.
Está acá.
Esto tendría que jalarlo.
Ya está.
Ya tengo mi api-key.
Ahora, vamos a añadir el body.
Send body, abelito.
Y acá vamos a dejarlo así.
Y ahí son using field below.
Y aquí vamos a colocar lo que necesito, el number.
El número.
Perdón, perdón, perdón.
No hay mayúscula.
Estamos casi, casi.
Tiene que ser casi los mismos parámetros que han creado
anteriormente.
Number, lo mismo.
Aquí está, number, lojar.
Ya.
¿Qué más necesito?
Necesito el texto o el mensaje.
Voy a colocar texto.
Y aquí voy a colocar el mensaje.
Puedo colocar mensaje.
Esperaremos prueba con un hola primero, ya que me responda.
Una vez que hagamos eso, ya podemos ejecutarlo.
Ya.
¿Qué más haber?
Adoption, Lovers, Watch this, and the Lord Christ.
Podemos añadir una respuesta, pero todavía no.
Ojo, ahí ya podemos colocar un montón de cosas, pero todavía
no.
Hasta ahí.
Esto debería de estar normal.
Ya.
A partir de acá voy a empezar a trabajar con mis agentes.
Dentro de mis agentes, ya voy a tratar de trabajar acá.
Hago doble click.
Aquí dice, conector, checker note.
Van a colocar y call define below.
Y aquí no van a colocar el prompt.
Sé que dice prompt user message.
Esto es justamente el mensaje de su cliente.
Y aquí van a colocar de su mensaje, ojalá no más.
Ya, ya hice un punto message.
Ahora, ¿qué más enable feedback model?
Opción.
Vamos a dar opción.
Ya, vamos a añadir en opciones para colocar
System Message.
Ya.
Y aquí es donde sí o sí tienen que dar el prompt.
Ese es el prompt que necesitamos.
Ahora, en este caso, por ejemplo,
yo quiero que todo lo que me envía el cliente,
digamos que no sé, quiero hacer una cita con un doctor,
ya.
O quiero hacer una cita para no se vender un terreno o demás.
Entonces, sí o sí se tiene que, en este caso,
la empresa darme una agenda.
Por ejemplo, a ver, ¿dónde hay afluencia bastante de empresas
que necesiten algo de calendarios?
Obviamente, hay en industrias que son venta de terrenos,
doctores, medicinas, bancos, incluso para ir al hospital.
O sea, se filas, ¿no?
Entre lo más aconsejable es que un sistema, sí o sí,
les dé hora, la fecha correspondiente.
Incluso para un paciente, ¿no?
El paciente no debería de chocar con otro paciente para,
porque obviamente son un turno.
Y a veces las especialidades en medicinas son escasas en algunos
hospitales de primer, segundo nivel.
Ya entonces, aquí ese prompt, yo lo voy a hacer.
Ya los tenías, yo tengo un prompt, se van a copiar.
Os voy a mostrar mi prompt.
Ahí está.
Este es mi prompt.
Ya dice, eres un asistente especializado únicamente en
gestión de citas de Google Calendar mediante mensajes
recibidos desde WhatsApp.
Aquí está.
Fecha y hora actuar y le doy no.
Aquí por si acaso, cuando ustedes se hagan sus prompts,
siempre añadan esto.
Bien, estoy añadiendo JavaScript.
¿Por qué JavaScript?
Porque lo interpreto de mejor manera y actualiza los datos
de manera directa.
Mira, ¿qué otro?
Otro.
Aquí va a haber otros más.
Bueno, 8, 3 o 4, que voy por ahí.
Ya.
Entonces, ¿qué implica el prompt?
Fíjense.
Son horaria.
¿Vos ustedes pueden cocar Santa Cruz?
UTC no sé, menos 5, porque somos 4, si ya no me acuerdo.
Varié por minutos, pero.
Luego, fíjese, no debes responder preguntas fuera de la
gestión de citas.
Si el usuario realiza consultas generales respondo
únicamente, solo puedo ir a la gestión y consultar.
Estamos creando citas y eliminación de citas.
¿Qué acciones?
Cree cita, consultar cita.
O sea, el cliente puede hacer esto.
Crear una cita, consultar una cita, reprogramar una cita o
eliminar una cita.
Incluso para cada uno de estos puntos, ustedes pueden darle
la fecha.
Porque imagínense, yo tengo cita con el doctor Mañan y lo voy
a cancelar faltando media hora.
El sistema debería de denegarme, ¿no?
Para evitar, porque a última hora,
eliminar todo no es obviamente lógico.
Y todos esos puntos, los puntos más detallados debería de
estar.
Por eso es que si os es necesario, trabaja con un plan
bastante ideal, adecuado.
Ya aquí está, ¿cómo se creó una cita?
¿Cómo se reprograma?
Todo lo estoy dando al sistema, a mi IA para canalizar y
hablar de lo demás.
Incluso le doy los días.
Hoy, o en fin, interpreta correctamente las expresiones
como hoy, mañana, pasado, el lunes, próximo lunes.
Y esto también es un coloquio que se utiliza bastante en
diferentes regiones, no solamente de Bolivia, ¿no?
Sino del mundo, porque quizás nosotros, en vez de decir
próximo mes, hay otra persona que lo dice de manera diferente.
Y a veces la IA puede interpretar muy erroneamente.
Y esa parte, sí o sí hay que tratar de colocar todo este
pronto.
Este pronto se está pasando.
Lo voy a juntar al caso al clasio.
Pero eso voy a pasar ahorita para que se quieran se pruebas y
me están siguiendo.
Lo cual lo dudo, pero espero que se.
Pero si no, y los envío al pronto.
En más de ese pronto, ustedes pueden cambiar a ventas,
cambiar a otras cosas y listo.
Entonces, ese pronto voy a colocar acá.
Listo.
Una vez que lo colocan ahí, voy a hacer lo siguiente.
Vamos a elegir el modelo.
Ya, ¿a qué más puedo elegir?
¿Por qué?
¿Por formato?
¿Option?
Bueno, aquí fíjense.
Podemos colocar máximas iteraciones.
Retornar, algunas rapes, bien.
Está bien.
Y pueden aumentar un montón de cosas.
Ya.
Ahora sí, lo voy a asegurar.
Vamos a elegirnos un modelo previo.
No sé si esta cuenta su credencia la tienen que activarlo.
Luego, bueno, yo voy a elegir YEPT5 mini, así que no hay
problema.
O sea que este me genera gastos de que vamos a elegir el 8.
Oh, 4 mini.
Oh, dónde está la suba.
Donde está?
Donde está YEPT5, YEPT9, ¿no?
El 4 mini.
Oye, ¿por qué no se va a consumir?
Bueno, son de datos.
Tóquenos, gasten los últimos.
Quiero recomiendo que cuando trabajen con un sistema,
lo más adecuado, lo más ansioso que su sistema sea.
El último, contar que responda y sea rápido, me lío.
Ya, ¿qué más podemos añadir?
Nada más.
Vamos a hacer el cheat de pericoes.
Listo.
Ya, ahora, dentro de esto, generalmente,
ya podemos trabajar.
A ver, haré un ejemplo.
Ahora, ¿qué proceso?
Voy a de nuevo mandar mi, no sé si este está activado,
enviado o activado.
Si ahora más activado.
A ver, si yo mando ahorita, debería de capturar menos datos.
Ya.
Pero ahorita no me vas a responder todavía la IA,
porque solamente quiero que funcione.
A ver, dame un ratito.
Voy a activar.
Voy a mandarme un mensajito.
Pero un rato.
Esto.
Ahora, si voy a enviarme un hola y me tiene que responder un
hola.
Listo.
Y escucha.
Está procesando.
Esperemos un rato.
Y ya me envió.
Ya, y me dice hola.
Bueno, se va a mostrar para que me crean.
Ya.
Agua, y cuivi, ¿음?
Buek costo.
Ahora cominking, ¿persilias?
I go compte a su amigo o a su Teraz verdad lo uní,
¿xx86?
por ejemplo ya me he escrituado dice hola 817 pero eso me ha respondido pero por qué me
ha respondido hola porque no le generó todavía el aspecto técnico del mensaje si vuelvo de
nuevo mi http donde dice hola debería estar ahora si el mensaje vos hola y le voy a jalar
lo put esto ahora sé si lo vuelvo a ejecutar debería de activarse voy a volver a ejecutar
voy a vendarle hola quiero una cita
ya está procesando ahí está pensando y lo hace más rápido y ahora lo voy a volver a mostrar
fíjense qué me dice
para qué día deseas agendarme y ya me están ducits listo en ya funciona pero ahora quiero
ver esto que lo haga de manera de mi google calendar que lo trabaje mis mensajes que
lo trabajen correos que me lo guarden pdf o sea ya se puede hacer un montón de cosas no
para eso ya está lo que son tools ya entonces los tools
al principio de la clase y hemos activado mi google calendar voy a irme directamente
a ello ya así que voy a entrarme acá donde está bueno estoy ahí no voy a venir acá voy a irme
acá y voy a irme directamente a calendar
ya en mi calendario voy a colocar voy a ignorar estos
voy a colocar un nuevo calendario crear calendario voy a decir no sé cita médica
y lo crean
y esto ya se creó
aquí está cita médica vuelven hacia atrás y aquí debería de aparecer la cita médica ya estoy
previsando este los demás para que no los desconozca y pueden colocarse en los listos venimos acá
ahora y ahora puedo elegir esa parte ya hago clic y vamos a irnos a calendar
hay dice google calendar tool ya hago clic
voy a borrar este un rato y aquí me trabaja con otro ticket
siempre trabajé muy aparte cada proceso lo voy a borrar y voy a colocar
administración de citas
listo vengo ahí y lo voy a dejar hasta ahí
no solamente puede haber un calendario puede haber un montón de calendarios pero ahorita
vamos a ver bastante lo que quiero en este caso es identificar mi proceso a o click
aquí dice google calendar count ahí está yo ya tengo esto ustedes pueden crear una nueva credencial
ya digamos que lo voy a borrar esto para hacerlo con ustedes voy a borrarlo bueno se lo abritó así
ya saben el que ahorita hemos hecho en principio de la clase este es su
idea de su clócons y este es el secreto y la se ve hecho que es lo que hemos hecho acá
el secreto y mi ad eso nomás lo copian y lo colocan ok ok y listo los activar ya ya hemos
hecho varios los mentales con calendar ya eligen ese y aquí ya podemos empezar a analizar algunos
puntos esos puntos me van a salir para muchas cosas set automáticos manualmente vamos a colocar
primero ya descripción dice creating un evento en google calendar
aquí vamos a colocar lo siguiente usar
le vamos a hacer iphone usar
porque no quieres esto no hay eso porque
usar
esta herramienta
cuando
el usuario o cliente
de
crear una cita
listo resource evento operación crear ahora vamos a seleccionar
ahí debería de aparecer fíjense acá cita médica dice me ha parecido
hago click ya trabaja automáticamente ya ya podemos ahorita hacerlo de manera automática
ahora fijense acá
está esta hora que pasa acá y este es interesante porque automáticamente quiero que la y ya lo
haga ya no quiero ya estar recepcionando fechas haciendo cada punto o sea da flojera en los polars
ya entonces vamos a utilizar algunas cabezas voy a venir acá a fails y vamos a colocar en
este caso algunas descripciones a ver que podamos utilizar el caixa
summary sería un summary un resumen y en este caso net more defined this
podemos adhesen algunas cosas más a esto automáticamente ya lo hace
un resumen más que todo nada de todo lo que ha pasado luego necesito digamos
un lugar o sea que lo guarden vas a lugar que lo está enviando y listo estamos click
y automáticamente lo hace
que más necesito las descripciones descripciones o sea que descripción está utilizando el cliente
lo va a guardar la ida así que automáticamente lo guardamos ya el esto ya entonces lo podemos
y ejecutar incluso a ver vamos a ver
voy a volver a ejecutar
vamos a volver a ejecutar la mostrador voy a volver a mandar mi
otro mensaje de mi celular
voy a de nuevo ejecutar wolf low
quiero agendar una cita para el martes de la semana siguiente
se puede a horas no sé 4 pm
listo le mando
ya está
la procesando
listo ya me ha generado ahora me está preguntando ahorita me dice podrías confirmar si te refieres
al martes 4 de julio además qué título deseas para la cita y le voy a decir eh voy a escuchar de nuevo
en sí por favor
ponle ponle
de título
revisión médica craneal
esto y el enviado está procesando
genera y sí ya me está preguntando para qué qué día de esa endocita para la revisión que le voy a
cocar martes
le voy a enviar de nuevo a ver si martes está acordando por si acaso
eso está acordando qué días ya ya y ahí lo va a guardar dios
a qué hora ahora me dice que todos eso tiene su prompte está bastante
interesante
el nuevo escuchar 16 pm
ya listo
listo ya está
a ver perdón me escrité escriptoma
ya y se acuerda se está acordando porque aquí están viendo mis ejecuciónes lo de las salidas
ahí está
están viendo nada
sí le voy a decir y ahí van a por eso ya pueden contabilizar cuántos mensajes están utilizando
ya van a ver mi respuesta
ya ahí está pero vamos a ver acá ustedes ya tienen que trabajar la parte de programs y demás
ya ya van a actualizar y se va a actualizar
ya por aquí lo está sino está hay que mejorar prompt
el coato
ah cierto
preguntenle cosas obvias ya porque martes yo le dije que
martes 4 pero el 4 sábado
ya es eso pero no solamente esos chicos miren aquel que vamos a hacer
aparte de la google calendar pueden añadir y lo siguiente
ya por ejemplo esto puede ser aquí tienen que especificar igual
guardar citas eso me olvide
guardar citas
ya listo ahora otro
pueden hacer lo siguiente igual aquí pueden añadir otro otro calendario
pero con qué objetivo
con el mismo objetivo de que eso algunas fechas no pueden sobreponerse
no pueden sobreponerse entonces aquí podrían colocar
eh
eliminación de cites eliminar cita
o sea que tengo sus susperios siendo acuenta cuando estaba preguntándole cuando estaba hablando con la lla
me estaba diciendo si quiero crear eliminar todo solo me hago para eso me de hecho no
en eso estoy haciendo
aquí pueden crear más de sus ya y aquí igual pueden trabajar de la misma manera
hacer el calendario automáticamente manual descripción e
utilizar esto si el usuario quiere eliminar cita
evento lo dejamos ahí seleccionamos la misma cita médica
lo atuntamos atuntamos y listo ya ahí pueden ejecutar pueden añadir descripciones y automáticamente
igual
demás
ya listo una una vez que hacemos eso
ahora no solamente puede haber un un usuario puede haber dos esto por ejemplo puede ser
netamente para el la persona el cliente o usuario pero el médico debería tener otro webhook
ya ocho webhook
entonces de webhook ya puede ser ya para doctor muy aparta acá
pero si no quieren hacer esto y hacer muchos webhooks
pueden también trabajar con lo siguiente pueden venir acá y pueden colocar la la variante if
if pues el if en avance bueno la medida ustedes
en cole en cole cuando avanzamos informatic se ven en el if no es si tal cosa está
se cumple si no no solamente es una condición hay pueden utilizar valores es decir
puede no utilizar qué voy a tener qué entrada si si tal usuario escribe tal cosa haya si el número
de tal persona es igual al número de tal persona pero vamos a lo probar
webhook
otro webhook digamos de acá lo voy a dejar acá
digamos nos aquí estoy seleccionando un número ya y aquí voy a colocar no sé vamos a colocar
el método webhook y lo mismo con ese mismo estamos trabajando solamente aquí tendría que
aquí tendría que trabajar con el mismo orl del de la evolución api no
sería con otro número pues no es bueno esto trabajarlo así siempre esto sería necesario
ponerlo acá pero se puede hacerlo siempre se manejan solamente no lo van a dejar aquí
pueden comparar no si el valor 1 70008 612 si es igual al valor 2 70005 5500 digamos
vamos a dar de condición antes y a otro valor si es igual si es igual tu tanto tal tal número
haya que me diga es verdad y me lleve otro campo y si no me llevo otro campo si es que
me genera dos despuestas no y entonces lo pueden duplicar nomás
y en base voy a originar más procesos no porque estoy yo sería así
copio esto todo esto van a ser tanto lío y esto pegamos
y aquí atendrían dos webhooks para un proceso y para otro proceso con este y ya nada más
bueno en el módulo 2 si es que va a haber módulo 2 y vamos a hacer bps bps y es más en
adentro pero antes de terminar la clase
aquí van a ser una vez que hagan esto ya vienen acá
vayan a producción se copian esto y lo van a volver a cambiar a mi evolución api acá
acá
a webhooks y le da nuevo acá
y colocando que reintelgar tanto listo ya está con eso ustedes que van a lograr
quién estén haciendo cada vez ejecutar ejecutar ejecutar automáticamente dispara siempre
una vez que hagan eso o bien hasta que lo apague en su cómpulo cierran su bóker o cierran su
cómpulo o sea este consuelo si lo cierran esto bien mente chao pero una vez que hagan eso
aquí colocan publicar publican y le van a dar por ejemplo empresa médica no se inventan
lo publican con eso
ya trabajan y aquí van a colocar aquí no es necesario
colocar nada y ya está y ya está trabajando de manera automática suene chon
ya sin este solamente en sus computadores deberían de prender esto
deberían de prender su docker minimizarlo y dejarlo prendido todo el día en los de
escritoria y con eso automáticamente todos sus temas vas a solito sin estar comprando de la
novedad más siempre es listo chicos ha sido un gusto vamos a quedar ahora para sus
los esos
es siete participantes van a defender el nueve ya saben se ve comentado y habíamos quedado en
que este sábado no vamos a pasar para que vean a basar en sus proyectos y
el 11 empezarían otro 7 y por último los que quedan el 16 de julio
ya ahora para terminar más rápido si desean podemos hacerlo seguido es decir
9 10 11 yo voy a estar creo que en vacaciones de mi trabajo unas unas semanas las siguientes
semanas y que podemos aprovechar el ya terminar las clases y no alargamos hasta el 16
no podemos terminarle mismo nueve toditos yo me quedo aunque tres horas con ustedes pero de una vez lo
por el término ese día si desean y mejoras esa libran y están libres y ya no estén que
así por ojo no tienen que existir todos solamente las personas que están listas ya los demás
tienen libros igual pero depende ustedes ahora si voy a sacar asistencias
vemos rato voy a enviar un formulario al whatsapp
para ver qué opciones están eligiendo ya vemos los chicos voy a sacar asistencias
y
no me acuerdo
ahora si tenemos ratito chicos
ya que nos terminamos ahorita voy a llamar el listo igual pero se crea un cachoso ustedes
mil discursos por no responderle a algunas personas a estas teoritas con semana de
masacres igual y el examen es y no puedo ir a responder a casi nadie esta semana y así voy a
estar hasta el siguiente lunes porque sigo tomando exámenes y también me están tomando examen así
que está medio raro eso pero justo estoy en semana de masacres chicos mil disculpas
si no les respondo espero que me entiendan ya les digo a los veis responder aunque en la noche o en
madrugada en cuanto pueda
tenemos ratito mas es que ultima tiempo fácil voy a empezar a dejar de compartir
ya hoy día somos 14 ya en su idea voy a ver mas eliminados
deben estar viendo creo portugano no se que esto jugando que todos estaban con eso
y ya no es va a haber pon sexo para ustedes ahora si
mal el malista de ratito voy a dejar de probar